hi this is Nick Carnac today we're going
to talk about using parcel which is a
web application Butler that offers
blazing fast performance with zero
configuration let's talk about some of
the features parcel provides parcels
blazing-fast bundle times are
accomplished via worker processes that
use multiple CPU cores during builds
rebuilds on the other hand are even
faster because it uses the file system
cache it can automatically bundle all
your assets and has support for
JavaScript CSS HTML file assets and more
all without the need for plugins
it also supports automatic code
transformation using babel post CSS and
post HTML parcel can split your code
without any configuration it uses the
dynamic import syntax to split the
output bundles and you end up loading
only files that are needed during the
initial load it also supports hot module
replacement without any configuration
parcel will automatically update the
modules in the browser as you make
changes to your code another useful
feature it provides is friendly error
logging partial prints syntax
highlighted code frames when it
encounters errors so you can pinpoint
the problem let's dive into some code
first let's create a new NPM project
then we're going to install the react in
react Dom packages followed by parcel
bundler notice that the name of the
library is parcel - bundler we need to
install it as a dev dependency in
addition you also should consider
installing it as a global dependency
with the - G attribute
so that you can run the parcel command
from the command line I'm not going to
do it on my machine because it's already
installed globally but once that's ready
what we could do is create a source
folder with an app GS file and create a
functional react component here first I
need to import react from react followed
by the react Dom module then I'm going
to create my app component as a
functional component and return a div
with an h1 tag with hello world as part
of the text there I use the Emmet syntax
to generate this next we're going to
render the app in the Dom using react
Dom render and we're going to pass it
app followed by a link to the root
element which we will create next in the
index.html file I'm going to give this a
title real quick and then let's create a
div element with the root tag again I'm
using the Emmet syntax and we're going
to create a script element with the
source attribute that points to app GS
all right let's go ahead and run this
I'm going to clear the console and type
in parcel and point it to my index.html
file notice that it starts building some
of the internal dependencies and
packaging it and it's done in about
three and a half seconds it runs on the
default port one two three four on
localhost so I'm going to open that link
in the browser
and there you go we have our hello world
react application running in a matter of
minutes using parcel with no
configuration now let's go back to the
App Gia's file and update our title here
and call it hello parcel world and I'm
going to save this and the moment I save
it the application gets rebuilt much
faster this time
and hello parcel world shows up on the
right as well that's using the HUD
module replacement feature and parcel
now notice a couple of folders that have
been created here there is a cache
folder with a bunch of files that parcel
uses internally so that it can rebuild
much quicker in addition it creates a
disk folder by default which contains
everything that is public facing so our
index.html file is present there with a
slight modification parcel replaced the
pointer to AB CS with the bundled app GS
file in addition there's also a map file
which is useful for debugging purposes
and as used by the browser so parcels
done all that work for us with zero
configuration next let's go ahead and
add an apt of CSS file in our source
folder and we'll give our h1 tag your
color gray I'm gonna save that go back
to abjure yes I simply need to import
hat dot CSS and when I save notice that
parcel built it and if I were to refresh
the project here I don't see my changes
here and that's because when you add new
files you need to restart parcel so I'm
going to kill this and then rerun parcel
source index HTML and it rebuilds
everything and it doesn't connect to the
browser automatically so you have to go
back and hit refresh
but the moment I hit refresh
notice that the text shows up in grey
let's go ahead and add an app dot s CSS
file I'm going to define a variable
called color and give it a value black
then we are going to set this value on
the body background color by referencing
dollar color and I'm gonna save this
followed by referencing it under the app
G has file and notice that parcel is
installing node sass and it's pulling in
all the dependencies that it needs
automatically and it's going to build
that a CSS file for us and since I've
set up to integrate with CSS we should
see the background color change on the
right and that worked this time without
a restart because internally parcel had
integrated with the CSS loader now let's
add a reference to a logo real quick I'm
gonna pull in a logo file from my other
screen alright we're gonna copy it under
source and let's reference that file as
logo from dot slash parcel logo SVG now
the moment I save it project rebuilds
and nothing happens that's because we
haven't added any reference here I'm
going to add the image tag and point the
source to the logo file that was
referenced above and hit save here and
voila we have the SVG logo loading
without any configuration we have
created a very basic react application
with your reference to a CSS file an S
CSS file an SVG logo and we're using the
ESX syntax
and we did all of that within a matter
of minutes without any configuration
that's the power of parcel and it's
going to make webpack obsolete before we
wrap up here I want to show you one more
thing let's say we wanted to use the D
structuring operator for props that are
passed in and reassign it to rest if I
were to save this notice a couple of
things are going on here first we have
an error message to the right where
parcels telling us that it does not
understand what those three dots
represent that's because babble does not
support the spread operator by default
so we need to import one of the plugins
for Babel so I'm going to install as a
dev dependency Babel plugin babble -
plugin - transform - object - rest -
spread that's pretty long for a package
name so let's hope that works that's
going to import the package and the next
thing we need to do is we're going to
create a dot babel RC file parcel we'll
read that file if it's available and we
want to set the plugin plugins property
to utilize the transform object rest
spread plugin so I'm going to go ahead
and save that let me clear the console
here and we're going to restart parcel
and notice that it's built now because
we stopped parcel we need to refresh the
page here and voila now we have the
ability to use the destructuring
operator so that's how you would
introduce configurations as needed all
right that brings us to the end of the
video hope you enjoyed it if you have
any questions or comments write them
below
subscribe to my channel to be notified
of future videos thank you